I love Nightmare Before Christmas it's a
classic you're going to behave yourself
in Gotham so that he can watch a movie
no days off oh my God you guys are tough
keep the change you filthy animal the
holidays the season of giving and what
better place to ask people their
favorite Christmas movie than Los
Angeles ComicCon let's talk to folks on
the
[Music]
[Applause]
street Christmas vacation I'm up at
Christmas Carol Star Wars Christmas
Special A Christmas Story a white
Christmas I love Nightmare Before
Christmas I going to say home alone I
love Elf just will farell and it's
wonderful classic
beautiful ow son of a nutcracker Eight
Crazy Nights for the holiday season of
Christmas Hanukkah whatever you
celebrate yeah Gremlins I love horror
movies and Halloween's the best so
Halloween bleeding over into Christmas
is good they're so cute they're so
cute
Iron Man 3 Iron Man 3 it's a Shane black
movie he loves making Christmas movies I
think that's a quality answer people
don't even consider it a quality movie
Die Hard Die Hard is a Christmas movie
Die Hard you're saying all the right
things right now utilizes the holiday
spirit and yet throws you a big action
thing in the middle the plot revolves
around the reestablishment of family and
bringing the love back together and get
everyone back together on the holidays
and overcoming struggle to do so and he
kills a guy and puts a Santa hat on him
no I have a machine gun ho
ho the Santa Claus cuz I just like to
watch a guy get fat for from doing
nothing he's not doing anything wrong
it's just happening to him and it's my
biggest fear but I like to watch it
going to say It's a Wonderful Life
starring what's it um Jimmy Jimmy
Stewart Jimmy Stewart James Stewart and
Betty grael she's not in it and then
I've always wanted to ask toala what is
the best holiday movie my guilty
pleasure is jingle all the way with
arold Schwarzenegger black panther likes
jingle all the way did not have that on
the old bingo card you can always count
on
[Music]
me we're here at La ComiCon we brought
along the new Rotten Tomatoes the card
game so we're going to play with some
folks here asking them can you nail the
Tomato Meter score for the first Home
Alone movie so what do y'all think the
very first home alone is on the Tomato
Meter if yall get it within 15% I'm
going to give you this game okay is this
going to be really high or really low or
you wouldn't be asking I feel like that
one has to be like 90 I would hope it's
a at least a four it's out of 100 and so
yes I'd hope it was at least four to
four I'd say they gave it a 90 see
that's probably only in the 70% range
mid90s I probably would say like 82% I
was say 78 96 and you're going to get 75
you guys know how to play this because
it is 65% fresh on the Tomato Meter
surprising it's it's very low can you
believe that this country has no taste
the audience score is is above 80%
though well that's okay well that's good
that that feels like it doesn't work for
you that is shocking 115 certified
critics have reviewed the movie 65% of
them thought it was a good film that's
why it's got the Tomato Meter score and
you feel like that number should be
higher oh yeah 100% ooh I'd give it a
cool 80 85% cool 85% but it's good news
for Haley because you have won yourself
your very own Rotten Tomatoes the card
game you were right on the money so you
get the card game sir tell he was right
it's almost
Christmas Hey look it's it's up to him I
hope hopefully he wants to play it with
you but it is it's his version of the
card game so and now it's just your job
to beat him at it there you go just
seeing a US Marshall do the Kevin
mallister face is enough for your own
version of Rotten Tomatoes the card game
next time I interview youall to future
convention let me know who's better at
the game we're going to make it a
drinking game if you're over
21 thank
[Music]
you oh I can't remember his name but
from Bad Santa Oh Billy Bob Gordon yes
it's Billy Bob Thorton from Bad Santa
that's the best Santa Claus oh uh uh
David Harbor David Harbor from violent
night is a good answer that was pretty
cool that was pretty Co that was pretty
cool I wasn't sure how a man on the law
felt about that movie know the law oh
God what's his name name the Tim Tim no
get there Woody Allen I think his name
Tim Allen Tim Allen there we go there we
go there we go we don't need to say
anything else about it but I think you'd
rather see Tim Allen coming down the
chimney Tim Allen okay so you do like
the Tim Allen movies absolutely you got
to give it to Tim Allen man I mean he
yeah you got to give it to Tim Allen he
not a Santa Claus he's the Santa Claus
absolutely I mean he had to off another
one in order to become Santa Claus
anyway so yeah you you do have to murder
the current Santa Claus to become Santa
Claus you got Richard attenburrow was
the newer Santa from America on 34th
Street Kurt Russell is Santa Claus
that's true I haven't seen the second
one of that though I only saw the first
one oh you got to see the second one
right my bad I don't know I I don't
think I've seen either one I just love
that Kurt Russell is Santa Claus
probably the one in Polar Express
because I'd like to believe that he's a
metaphor for some omnipotent being like
Beyond Santa Claus Tom Hanks was in The
Polar Express that's very good played
everyone he's America's father and he's
America Santa he's kind of like a band
member who can play all the instruments
me that's right
thanks for tuning in on the street
comment right now and let us know what's
your favorite movie to watch during the
holiday season I'm Mark Ellis on behalf
of the whole team at Rotten Tomatoes
good night to all and to all a good
night thanks for checking this FD out
head over to rotten tomatoes.com for
everything in the world of movies TV and
in between happy holidays Rotten
Tomatoes how eater Christmas in general
how uh what I have a machine gun ho ho
ho Merry Christmas you filthy
animal you were ready for that all day
weren't you